un Halo de Esperanza para los residentes
del noroeste de Siria ya que Damasco
dice que aprobó la entrega de ayuda
humanitaria a las zonas controladas por
los Rebeldes una decisión que
facilitaría el acceso de los convoys al
territorio un segundo convoy de ayuda de
la ONU llegó hace poco 14 camiones
cargados con diversos suministros de
Socorro y materiales necesarios para
tiendas de campaña e higiene así como
algunos alimentos se entregará a una
organización asociada de la ONU que
opera en las zonas liberadas Desde allí
la ayuda se distribuirá a Los afectados
por el terremoto en la región solo unos
pocos camiones pudieron atravesar los
territorios controlados por distintos
grupos Rebeldes y opositores por el paso
fronterizo de bab al jaguar pero los
daños causados por el terremoto han
dificultado el paso la ayuda humanitaria
se espera con impaciencia en zonas como
aquí en azad este hombre se ha reunido
por fin con su hijo de un año después de
que lo descubrieran solo en un hospital
toda la familia había quedado sepultada
bajo los escombros
sentimos el terremoto sobre las 4 o de
la mañana mi mujer que en paz descanse
me dijo que sacara a los niños y
entonces se produjo el segundo temblor
nos caímos y me encontré bajo los
escombros gracias a Dios pude respirar
por un agujero
mi hijo lloraba al lado le oía pero no
podía llegar hasta él
y animaba bastante
Naciones Unidas Dice que hasta 5,3
millones de sirios pueden quedarse sin
hogar tras el desastre decenas de
aviones cargados con ayuda han llegado a
las zonas controladas por el gobierno
sirio principalmente de Aliados del
régimen como Irán Rusia y los emiratos
árabes Unidos